recently my students asked me this
particular question this integration
which it's a fairly straightforward
integral to do however when I was with
my students what I showed them was a
technique that comes from the the
mathematics Advanced Course in New South
Wales so it's a little bit long and
laborious and involves a lot of
algebraic manipulation however it does
work and you get the right answer that's
where I started however unfortunately
during my class I ran out of time to
explain there's a more sophisticated
clever method that you can use that
isn't in the mathematics Advanced course
it's in the mathematics extension one
course so if you're an advanced student
you can still tackle a question like
this but if you're an extension one
suited you know a bit of a technique
which makes it a lot simpler and a lot
faster so I'm going to show you that
technique now it's called integration by
substitution when you have a look at the
question you can see that there is this
square root of x that comes up twice in
the integrand and that's part of what
makes this question a little bit messy
because the square root of x when we're
in the country types of integration we
would normally write that as x to the
power of a half and then we can deal
with all of the indices going up divide
Etc it all does work out but it's it's a
highly error-prone method and square
roots are not nice things to integrate
especially uh when you see them like
this so one of the things we can do
is we can rephrase this question without
any square roots in it by making an
appropriate substitution so if for
example I introduce a new uh variable
and by convention we tend to call it U
so I'm going to say let U equal the
square root of x
what I can then do is I can rework this
integral so it's all in terms of this
new variable all in terms of U instead
of X and then it's going to be simpler
to integrate because there are no square
roots involved okay so the first thing
is I can say let U equals square root of
x and there's going to be if you think
about this
is going to be a couple of spots where I
can just substitute out here and here if
you think that's appropriate you'll see
why in a moment I'm going to do
something different with that but this
immediately gets rid of all the square
roots and that's kind of what our goal
was at the beginning however that
produces a different problem which is
that your integral is actually not with
respect to
um the variable that you want you have
this DX here which says Hey pay
attention to the x's in the integrand
and integrate with respect to those but
you're about to do this substitution
which gets rid of all the X's now you've
got use so how do you solve that problem
how do you make this an integral not
with respect to X but an integral with
respect to U
here's how you do it what you say is if
I have uh this statement here of you
equaling the square root of x what I can
do is I can work out an equivalent
derivative which gets things in terms of
not DX's but D U's and that will
translate our original integral into one
that integrates with respect to U
so to do that we just need to actually
calculate this derivative so it's the
derivative
of the square root of x which as we were
pointing out before it is X to the power
of a half so even though this method
does avoid a lot of the tedious square
roots and algebra that comes with that
you don't completely get away from the
the indices that were part of the
question however you're going to see
they do disappear pretty fast so all
we're going to do is we're going to say
just like we normally would we will
multiply by that power as it currently
is and then reduce the power by one and
so this in fact I could write as 1 over
2 square root of x that is the
derivative that I'm after now if you
have a look at this the reason why this
is interesting to me is because it
appears in my integrand in the first
place well it sort of does right can you
see that my original integrand has that
square root of x on the denominator I've
got a square root of x on this
denominator 2. the only difference is
there's a 2. now the two is no problem
because it's it's a constant coefficient
with derivatives and integrals you can
divide and multiply in and out by
constant coefficients as much as you
please so because number one they're
constant so they don't affect you know
what's happening with X and number two
excuse me provided that if you're
multiplying by something you divide by
that same quantity to kind of keep
things balanced you don't actually want
to change the integrand you just want to
make it look different so that it's
easier to integrate okay so that's
exactly what I'm going to do I'm going
to go back over to my original question
and I'm going to say well look what this
is equal to is If I multiply by a 2 out
the front I'm going to have the integral
of let's write all of this the same
in fact to make it even more obvious
what I'll do is I'll separate out this
part of the integrand from the
denominator part of the integrand so you
can see I've got a 1 on 2 root X
happening here so I hope that you can
see how this denominator has turned into
this term down here okay and then I've
I've multiplied by 2 divided by two
everything is all the same okay
now all of this like we mentioned before
is with respect to X but watch now as I
do some of this substitution right I've
got for starters
here's the square root of x which I'm
going to substitute for U and then
secondly what color should I use let's
use this I've got this one on two root
of x here that appears identically here
so I'm going to substitute that for d u
on DX like so
what does that give me well over here on
the left hand side here I'm going to
have two integral of here is the D on DX
that I had before so maybe I'll just
write that in an appropriate color do
you on DX in green then this square root
of x gets replaced by the U that I
introduced
plus b that's just a constant remember
so I'm not worrying about that too much
and then there's the DX so you can see
here that those DX terms even though d u
on DX is is much more than just a simple
fraction it's not like three quarters
right it's actually disguising a
limiting process it's the limit as DX
approaches zero etc etc despite that
that because you've got this same kind
of you've got this symmetric process
happening here right where you've got du
on DX and it interacts with the DX on
the end in such a way that you can
actually in this context treat them a
bit like fractions that just cancel out
with each other okay so please just hear
me though saying that it isn't just like
three quarters times four there's a lot
more going on underneath du on DX it
hides first principles and all of this
limit uh limiting idea it's a it's a
very sophisticated object so uh don't
treat it just like a fraction but in
this context we can actually
meaningfully cancel out the DX's with
each other in a manner of speaking so
what does that leave us with well the
two is still hanging out the front and
then you've got uh U plus b squared and
now we're integrating with respect to U
because you can see this is remaining it
hasn't been canceled
and this is a very straightforward
question to complete you can see I can
just use reverse chain rule I don't even
need to expand out right I'm going to
get uh two
um I'll leave that out the front and
then I've got a u plus B Cubed but then
you've got to divide through by this new
power right so that's going to be
two-thirds effectively because I'm
dividing by the three don't forget this
is an indefinite integral so I have a
constant
and that's it that's the answer now I
could stop there if the question was
just integrate as indeed it was um that
would be where I would uh stop of course
provided that I actually substitute back
the uh the root X that I sort of took
out in the first place uh but the
integration was all done by that point
anyway so this is it okay
now I'm satisfied with this answer but
some of you might find this a little bit
unsettling because you looked at the
answer you got before and it was it was
much longer it looked quite different so
I think it's worth because we've
approached this from one point of view
which is just expanding out all the root
X's canceling and so on and then
integrating and we've now taken quite a
different approach it's always worth and
for me quite satisfying to see that we
can confirm we get the right answer by
doing the expansion now as a secondary
thing and then seeing confirming that
we've got the same answer we got before
okay so here's what I'm going to do I'll
leave that two-thirds out the front four
now and then what I'm going to do is I
because I've got a cubed here right I'm
going to use in my mind what I know
about the binomial expansions now again
binomial expansions are an extension one
technique so if you're an advanced
student you're like I don't know what
we're talking about right well that's
why using this substitution technique
which comes from extension one it goes
with a result like this which allows me
to quite quickly without doing this bit
by bit expand out I know what my
coefficients are going to be they're
going to be 1 three three one I get that
from Paschal triangle or you could
confirm that using NCR notation in your
calculator
but effectively you're going to get this
term cubed then this term squared plus
one times one of these uh this term once
multiplied by two of these and then this
term three times so let's actually just
map that out
the square root of x cubed is going to
be X root X and from the previous
technique that should look familiar then
you're going to get the three lots of
the first term squared which is just X
multiplied by B which is just a constant
so I lamp it in there with the constant
coefficient
I get 3 again and this time I've got a 2
2 multiple multiplications of that
second term in the binomial and then one
of the first and then I complete with B
Cubed and then my constant integration
is still hanging out there okay
now you can see again I could leave that
there but just to get really close right
let's just expand out that two-thirds
into the rest of my brackets here not
much interesting happens here in the
front but in these two middle terms the
on three cancels with the threes so you
get two BX
2 b squared root X and then you get
something that puzzles you a little bit
because you've got two thirds B cubed
plus C and I didn't have that in my
previous answer what's going on there
what is up with this term and the answer
is have a think about this right we said
right out the gate the b in the original
question it's just a constant it's just
another number in there it could be one
or five or Pi or anything you like okay
importantly it doesn't affect the
integration we're not integrating with
respect to B we're integrating with
respect to X that's the variable well I
mean we integrated with respect to U
because we did a substitution but you
get the idea now given that that b is
just a constant right therefore what
you've got here on the end two thirds B
cubed plus C
that whole thing is just a constant so
therefore this term that you've got on
the end here is equivalent to the
original C that I got when I I expanded
the whole thing out I didn't do any
substitution whatsoever but it's just a
different constant when you do this
you've got a whole family of primitive
functions that all are legitimately the
uh the integral of this function when
it's an indefinite integral right
because any of these uh Expressions here
if I had all of these same things
and then instead of uh the two-thirds
being cubed plus C I just had a c if you
differentiated that you would still end
up with the same thing as you got in the
previous line because all of your
content integration would vanish when
you differentiate so therefore even
though it looks slightly different it is
the same answer and certainly when you
can compare
um you know these these lines of working
here were just a bonus to confirm that
we got the same answer as before so I
think it's pretty easy to argue that
certainly the algebra is simpler looking
at this technique as long as you know
how to use this integration by
substitution method which does require a
few fancy uh
what's the word I'm looking for a few
calculus you know backflips but they
save you a lot of time if you know what
they mean